so this should be a lot of fun hopefully
edifying for for all of us we
we talk a lot about we do a lot of
dating advice stuff so i thought today
we're gonna take a look at a dating
advice video which
originally was filmed i think in 1949
we know that these days people have no
idea what to do and that's very clear in
some of the videos we've done people
have no idea what to do in the dating
scene
let's go back to 1949 that was back when
they believed in chivalry and
self-respect and etiquette you know
there were no dating apps there was no
uh tinder chat
no snap bumble if you wanted a date you
had to ride your horse to the next town
of five days journey
then kill the bandits who had kidnapped
her that's what you had to do at least
in my imagination
let's check out this this old-timey
dating psa and let's
let's get the real scoop on on dating
let's see
[Music]
what's that
oh yes the ticket he told me about
well let's see what he has to say
here's the latest on my broken ankle
doc says i'll be all right only i have
to stay off
my feet for a week or so
okay i don't know just to stop it every
second i don't mean to be rude but why
is the kid reading like it's the first
time he's encountered
the written word in his life today
junior
uh maybe he's struggling because it's
cursive
the biggest waste of time in school is i
made us learn cursive and then i
graduated
and then i discovered that nobody in
actual adult human life
ever writes in cursive they may as well
made us become fluent in like
hieroglyphics or something one couple
that means a date okay now wait a second
the high teen carnival what kind of
debauchery is this
all right all right all right how you
doing
i thought we'd get something wholesome
from the 1940s you can let your kid go
on a date
to a carnival full of high teens
and the high part is it's kind of
redundant everybody is high at a
carnival we already know that
especially the people operating the
rides like the guy running the ride
is blitzed out of his skull and you're
putting your four-year-old onto this
spinning metal
death trap you're putting your child's
life in this man's hands
not a smart thing to do but this video
is taking a scandalous turn
i'm already a little bit disappointed i
was expecting something more buttoned up
than this
how do you choose a date whose company
would you enjoy
well one thing you can consider is looks
woody thought of janice and how good
looking she was
yes he'd enjoy that except
well it's too bad janice always acts so
superior and bored
she'd make a fellow feel awkward and
inferior
well perhaps someone who doesn't feel
superior there's betty
and yet it just doesn't seem as if she'd
be much fun
[Music]
what about anne she knows how to have a
good time
and how to make the fella with her relax
have fun too
yes that's what a boy likes he wants to
know he's appreciated
and would be fun on a date
okay i gotta say now i here's what i
like so far
i like that all the onus is being put on
the women
to impress the man that's the way it
should be for legal reasons that's
a joke for legal reasons i like how
we're ranking the different kinds of
women you're never gonna find this kind
of thing these days
here's what i don't like these kids are
way too young to be dating in the first
place
you shouldn't be dating until you're at
least 25 30 years old
at the youngest second anne here who
gets chosen
has the manners of a damned barn animal
chomping away at the cotton candy it's
disgusting chewing with her mouth open
no decorum no class i'm shocked that
these kinds of manners were considered
appropriate in the 1940s
the correct response as a gentleman if
you're dating a lady who eats like that
just say excuse me ma'am your manner of
eating repulses me
leave my presence this is dating 101.
when i was single i had at least 12
first dates
end that way you know speaking of kids
in the 1940s dating what you never want
to have to say is that your home got
stolen like mine did my home was stolen
i'm holding a copy of the legal title to
my home
in my hand this piece of paper could not
be anything but this is proof
that it's a legal title and my signature
on it is on it it says that my
that i sold my home even though i didn't
luckily this is just a demo
though from home title log here's how
cyber criminals get you the title
documents to our homes are kept
online the thief forges your signature
on a quit claim deed stating
that you sold your home and he's the new
owner you never know until until it's
too late and you've got the the late
payment or
eviction notices arriving that's why i
have
home title law the instant home title
lock detects
someone tampering with my home's title
to help shut it down
let's get you protected go to
hometitlelock.com and register your
address to see if you're already a
victim and
enter walsh for 33 days of protection
that's promo code walsh at
hometitlelock.com
the 1940s are dropping the ball so far
but let's let's give it another shot
let's watch again
oh mom is it all right with you if i
have a date saturday night
well of course you generally go out on
saturdays hello may i speak to mary
please but mom this is different
a date i well i haven't asked her yet
but i'd like to take aunt davis to the
high teen carnival oh
and a nice girl but a date
well you're rather young oh mom give him
a break
i think he can swing it we all have to
start sometime
well if you don't overdo on dating
ed knows what i mean weekends only and
not too late
so what what's going on here both boys
are talking back mouthing off to their
mother
what kind of res is this is what we call
respect
where is the father coming in with his
belt
ready to fix some attitudes the
old-fashioned way that's what i would
expect to see here
speaking of father why hasn't the father
been consulted about this date at all
why isn't ann's father being consulted
the proper way to get a date is to bring
gifts of
silver and gold to the lady's father and
ask for permission to court his daughter
if you get the okay and then the
courtship will last for about four days
and then you get married that's the way
that things are that's the way i assume
things were done not this liberal
nonsense we're seeing in the video
[Music]
it's a shame just a damn shame look at
that hijinks frivolity
dancing hot dogs totally inappropriate
unacceptable behavior
these kids should all be home engaged in
vigorous study and reflection
welcome to bible study we're all
children of jesus
now we see how we ended up where we are
today right we see that we see the
slippery slope because first you get you
got kids dancing at a carnival
and next thing you know [ __ ] is the
number one song of 2020.
it's not hard to see the trajectory but
feeling it's going to get a lot worse
now so that's that's the date
and now we get to um the end of the
night and let's see what what advice the
1940s can give us for
how to end a date how do you say good
night
perhaps don't
please
or it could go this way
well so long just like that
after all a girl likes to know you've
had a good time
so let's try saying good night again one
more way
well it's getting late yes it is
i'd ask you in for a bite to eat if it
were so late
um let's plan to get home in time for a
sandwich or something next time
say that sounds good i'll call you next
week
will you well thanks so much
i had no performance so did i good night
good night
no wrong see the appropriate way
to say good night is to walk the lady to
the door
no later than three o'clock in the
afternoon shake her hand and say
have a pleasant afternoon and then turn
around and walk away quickly no smile
no nothing suggestive like kissing
smiling laughing i have to say that the
the advice here turns out to be
far too progressive for my tastes
i always thought you know i should have
been born in the 1940s i think i should
have been born in the 1240s
silence foul temptress i thought we'd
get something wholesome here and
i apologize that we didn't what we get
instead is pure
unadulterated hedonism